[Music]
it is so much fun to be able to do that
and not have to fight Kevin for it hey
my name is Mark Barnard welcome to black
man beyond Episode two electric Boogaloo
here at the shiny a scum and villainy
Cantina for a nice intimate discussion
about things that go bump in the night
how's everybody doing tonight so good
are you sure like so good or just fine
I'm really good man thank you I
appreciate you asking that's very sweet
of you you were raised well I have I
have three amazing co-hosts who are
waiting in the wings who will be out
very shortly but first because it's
almost Halloween and clearly most of you
are at a Halloween party if you're not
here which is fine because we're gonna
be a little scary I wanted to talk about
the scariest thing that's ever happened
to me
because it feels like it's a good thing
to talk about a couple days before
Halloween when I was young and I know
it's hard to believe that that was there
was a time ago but uh but when I was
when I was like 20 years old my best
friend was a guy named Nick Nick is
Greek from Long Island New York
very sweet guy also the guy that you
would like whenever I was making short
films in high school I'd be like you
know what I could really use an ice
cream truck how do I get an ice cube
check not be like you know I got one
just give me a second I'll bring an ice
cream truck when do you need it like
Sunday afternoon no problem Nick was the
guy who could find anything anywhere
anytime so Nick and I were both Boy
Scouts he far longer than I I bounced
out of the Boy Scouts relatively young
because I thought the awesomest thing to
do would be to bring like Playboy
magazines to Boy Scout camp and it turns
out that they frown on that for reasons
I don't understand because it felt like
the best idea to me but Nick was like an
Eagle Scout like Nick went all the
[ __ ] way
but we both liked to go camping and
camping was cool like we lived in New
York and so within how are you could be
up in the Adirondacks it was gorgeous
and fall and the leaves are changing and
so I was a twenty Nick is a couple years
old stuck 22 I was in my last year of
college he had already graduated and he
was going to be a private investigator
was his dream he got his law degree and
he like he had a gun license like he was
that guy 22 years old who was like a
license to carry which seems like a bad
idea
even in 1994 this must have been so we
go we get in his car we just [ __ ]
start driving up into the woods the
middle of nowhere because that's the
best camp you know what a campsite
that's regulated and regulation is
[ __ ] so we just pulled off the side
of this road in the middle of nowhere
and and I was driving on his Volkswagen
GTI I felt so [ __ ] cute in my little
Volkswagen and I pulled off on the side
of the road and we're like alright let's
set up a tent and we'll light a fire
we'll start toasting marshmallows and
and you know we we brought Chef Boyardee
in cans and you just put the can on the
fire and you give it like 10 minutes and
it's hot and that's all you need it to
be like roasting hot dogs and [ __ ] and
then you know Sun Goes Down and we're
just [ __ ] hanging out and we're about
to go to sleep it must be like 10
o'clock at night and and we had both
like I am NOT like an experienced
woodsman nick is he grew up
upstate like his family had a house up
there so he's all about that woods life
but you know and I've been Cammy just
enough to not be like afraid of the
woods but we both heard this
blood-curdling scream like top of the
lung someplace not very far away just
full-on like out of a horror movie
some woman screaming her [ __ ] head
off and we look at each other
well like he heard that right yeah that
was real though right I think so where
the [ __ ] are we I'm not sure so so Nick
gets his his pistol and he hands me the
shotgun
I mean already the best idea ever right
just so we hands me the shotgun and
we're standing there like hello anybody
out there
nothing nothing another [ __ ] screen
right and so and then we start to hear
like footsteps not that far off like
just like pressing down on branches and
leaves and [ __ ]
and so I I RAC the shotgun and in case
you don't know what that sounds like
other than for movies
it is loudest [ __ ] thunder if you're
in the middle of nowhere so just that
like another [ __ ] scream and then
more footsteps and like we are two
twenty-something people who like one of
us might have been an athlete at one
point another one of us we had a law
degree was gonna be a [ __ ] private
investigator and and we're like we need
to go right right are we gonna be heroes
today no [ __ ] that
so like he I hand him the shotgun and
he's like kind of patrolling around the
campsite and I'm trying to break down
this [ __ ] tent and it's not working
cuz you got to do the thing where you
pull them apart and fold it and I wasn't
pulling I was just folding snap
splinters and pain and like trying to
shove this tent and this cooler and into
the back of a Volkswagen GTI which is
not really fit for cargo especially if
you don't fold it right and like so I'm
cramming this [ __ ] in there and he's
watching the car and I finally get
everything in the car and then
Volkswagen GTI is not known for its
off-road capabilities but here we are
[ __ ] off-road and we're a little bit
of panic and so I get behind the wheel
and I start spinning out the tires are
waving and I'm like careening off of
trees to get out of this weird-ass
middle of the woods [ __ ] and then we
get onto the highway and we drive like a
hundred miles an hour
to his house and we get there at like
four o'clock in the morning and his
parents wake up who were staying there
for for a stretch like what happened no
one like you know that traditionally we
are not like wimps about this right like
we're all good with camping like we're
not it's not a strange thing to us so
why are you here because we heard some
[ __ ] in the woods
and it wasn't cool but do you think it
was real
yes do you making pancakes now because I
was really like some pancakes to settle
my nerves that was the last time I went
camping and that is now like 20 years
ago and I think about it every Halloween
of the thing that I will never do
because [ __ ] of the woods bad things
happen there so yeah that's the scary
thing that's ever happened to me
thanks Nate tonight's gonna be a little
bit different as far as fat man beyond
goes sliced black man beyond we are not
going to be so much about the news
tonight though there is one new story
that we are going to talk about because
damn what to do so I'm going to call up
my guest toasts first I would like to
welcome to the stage Latoya morgen
[Applause]
Latoya is a screenwriter and television
producer of great renown she is
responsible for things like turn
Washington spies into the badlands and a
couple episodes of The Walking Dead and
for making AMC a better place by being
there you do what you can thank you are
we missing a mic or do we have three
okay up next I would like to welcome
Clark Wolfe to the stage
Clark is a horror of party par
excellence she was an actress and a host
and she's currently holding it down at
DC daily hey Clark and then finally Jen
Yamato who is a journalist for the Los
Angeles Times and a writer of such skill
and deafness and emotionality that she
makes it hard to be a writer yourself or
a journalist which is why I quit being a
journalist because she's too good at it
she's very good so hey Jane you get the
JLo however griots your favorites
alright so I think and my favorite part
is that I'm doing this with Clark who I
met in Romania yes the most horrific of
places well it has a history it has a
history we were both there on a junket
covering Dracula untold yes you don't
remember that one right no nobody should
it was relatively shitty it was the
first stab that Universal made it like
rebooting their high now see what I did
there
and rebooting their monster franchise
and it didn't work because they would
then put that [ __ ] to bed for a couple
of years and then the mummy which didn't
work and then they put that [ __ ] to bed
for a couple sofia boutella was a
wonderful mummy I really liked her as
the mummy that movie is nonsense but
she's great she's a best thing about it
down hey wait had a question regarding
your origin story of your friendship yes
what did you observe on set dear even
remember well it wasn't even set it was
a video job blu-ray junket home video
but so this this was amazing so okay
Dracula untold not great admittedly it
did make money
so we got to go on this trip and I will
say one of the cool things they did was
even though it just totally factually
inaccurate they tried to blend vlad the
impaler
and that with the dracula mythology that
we kind of know and so so that's weird
because it's not it doesn't involve Vlad
at all like the real Dracula book but we
got to tour Romania and see all of these
historical locations that Vlad lived and
ruled we went to the monastery where his
headless body was delivered like it was
for me mark was probably like did not
enjoy this but I was in heaven because
it was the most grand fabulous
historical thing that I would have
always wanted to do but would have never
been able to it was super metal ah and
the best part was they didn't shoot the
movie in Romania no they shot it like
Ireland
oh yeah and but they still did as a
[ __ ] Romania to show his [ __ ] that's
not in the movie for reasons it was
great I liked all of those reasons as I
got to go there so we could be standing
right here today
absolutely like that I don't know my
favorite part was that I went there I
was working for Playboy at the time and
and I went with the idea that like I'd
do this [ __ ] junket and I'd write
about the experience of the junket that
I'd interview one of the actors in the
movie at the end of it and one of the
actors I won't name who it was but it
wasn't the storm I'm not gonna name the
name but one of the actors was like I
don't want to talk to playboy and I was
like huh
I wonder why and and and the and the
publicist was like yeah he's just he
doesn't feel comfortable talking to
Playboy
so if you don't I mean you don't have to
do the interview you just got a free
vacation in Romania and I was like are
you sure though because this wasn't
cheap and my later on I would come to
the conclusion that said actor was
closeted and thought that talking to
playboy would in some fashion out him to
the world like I give a [ __ ]
but even if you wanted to lie about it
the people you lie to or playboy like if
you want to pretend that you're like you
know what I really love the ladies boy
do I ever the lie you tell to sell that
is [ __ ] playboy but did you notice how
in the movie they do not become vampires
by biting each other mmm because I
definitely noticed that yeah too good I
just thought it was very interesting I
think it's like they cut themselves and
you they feed you their blood or
something but there's no physical
contact between future vampires harsh
language so harshly so I I guess we
should start our little baby news bit
which is in case anybody was on Twitter
this weekend there was a there was a
sort of live stream of a of the Austin
Film Festival where the two guys who
made Game of Thrones DB Weiss and David
Benioff we're sort of doing this victory
lap of like hey we made Game of Thrones
that was awesome right let's tell you
how that happened and then they
proceeded to tell everything that they
did wrong over the course of making this
show which is like I didn't read the
books we just pitched the pilot we
didn't want to understand how the
characters worked we're not about that
we made a pilot that was like half as
long as it should have been and awful
and didn't get fired and then they just
gave us more money to reshoot the pilot
we don't know how to write four
characters so the actors pretty much did
most of that work we don't know how to
interface with our sort of production
head so like costuming don't know how
that works either
basically it was a litany of we either
didn't know learning on the job didn't
care and and somehow had a hit show and
somehow never got fired so it was this
weird like flex of privilege that seems
odd given that like dude you got an Emmy
for best [ __ ] drama like you could
have just never told anybody that you
pulled the heist of the century and just
gotten off scot-free but instead they
decided to say
here's how we fooled you it's like the
end of clue right like maybe it happened
like this and another [ __ ] way that
they kind of pulled the wool over
everybody's eyes including themselves
how did you guys react because I know
that's not the news well I will get to
the second part of the news which is
delicious but like I know that every
screenwriter than I know especially
every TV writer than I know who has been
trying their best to sell a [ __ ] TV
show and the response is always man you
gotta have more experience like we're
just not sure we can trust you with this
show you've never run a show before
despite having produced hundreds of
hours of television we're just not sure
you're ready every one of those people
is like have you seen these
[ __ ] who admittedly didn't know
how to I mean the thing that got me
about it and no one is trying to say you
shouldn't be allowed to learn on the job
I think the term that they used was film
school they got to use Game of Thrones
as their film school but that
opportunity is definitely not given to
people who look like me so that's the
problem that I have with it if it was
egalitarian and everybody got a chance
to [ __ ] up and make mistakes and even
get a shot to do this because I can't
even tell you how many meetings I've had
where I've left like enraged because all
I'm trying to do is get that first show
on the air and it's just super hard for
people who look like me yes yeah I think
- all I want to say all I want to
contribute is like I think there all of
that is so shitty and then on top of it
appearing to not have the humility to be
like boy we were lucky yeah boy like we
did all this stuff and the learning on
the job stuff and like all of this and
boy you know this is what this is how we
got better this is how we like you know
when we were so grateful for the energy
off of it was like yeah and that we wait
what
got really hard to the point where we
didn't want to do it anymore so we kind
of just gave up and things like was the
bad part or the I'm sorry not the bad
part but like the extra not great yeah
no is the Seuss on at the end it was a
bad finish off of a glass of wine that
every tastes like [ __ ] but it's it was
very much like we don't understand the
privilege that we had and don't have any
perspective on it whatsoever how do you
feel about it Jen objectively as a
journalist I agree yeah and I think when
you are two of now the highly paid
highest tonight creators in Hollywood
with very high-profile multi-billion
dollar deals i I think a little bit more
awareness is an order but also anything
it's illuminating and illuminating
moments like that have the ability to
shine a light in and start conversations
in the community and I think that's
actually a great thing is that now like
the industry can be like let's not do
that see what are they gonna say because
one of the things that also happened to
because I'm on weight Twitter way too
much which is bad but um there was this
weird kind of like backlash almost where
people were saying like oh you're just
so jealous of them because you know now
they're just laughing their way to the
bank and I'm like it's you're missing
the point entirely like no one is of
course please give me nine figures thank
you I'll take it they kind of said they
didn't try like no one told them to say
this they said it themselves and I'm
like so you kind of it was a weird cell
phone it was kind of odd as you wonder
though if people would be less
if more people loved how the show yes
that's a whole other podcast yeah I mean
and like HBO does that like they give
their creators an incredibly long leash
you know and most of the time it pays
out for them like Watchmen was an
incredibly long production process years
long of being in the room and and the
amount of resources and and and length
of rope that they gave to Damon Lindelof
to do that is unlike you would get
anyplace else then again Damon Lindelof
had already come off of lost had come
off of leftovers for them which did very
well so that length of rope is somewhat
warranted it's still anomalous in
television to get a couple of years to
do to produce you know nine episodes of
TV but very very hard totally I think
that's the thing that was missing from
the conversation that was online it's
people were missing the part that it is
very very hard to get one episode let
alone a season television and then
another season or could you imagine
getting to do your pilot over exactly
and not be removed or be assigned we're
you know we were talking about this at
dinner like not being it being assigned
somebody who's like okay hey this is a
veteran showrunner like this is somebody
who knows how to deal with big budgets
big productions they're gonna come on
you know for those three because clearly
the pilot was amiss yeah we we have to
scrap all of that like that's I have now
been on two television shows where the
executive producer has been relieved of
his duties
somewhere between production and
post-production and that's very common
today with it after in two different
incarnations is very totally and like
and those were experienced producers who
had done like hours and hours and hours
of television it just wasn't working and
they got fired for it or asked to leave
or creative differences or whatever
version of that story you know you want
to hear for those guys to like not even
get like hey can you actually do this
yeah we got this it's fine we just need
like a hundred million dollars more is
that cool yeah
you're alright in our book make us a
show just not as shitty as that one
that's that's what it's it's not what
they did it's what they were allowed to
do is sort of my issue with it hae-jin
what was the follow-up news to this Star
War so if you'll remember viewers about
two years ago DB Weiss and and and
Benioff Dave Benioff were granted a
trilogy of Star Wars movies okay I think
Kennedy you know set them down it's like
a you know what we like to cut of your
jib Game of Thrones is really good you
guys have a trilogy that's when she was
handing out trilogies like there was
candy at Halloween like you get a
trilogy you get a trilogy you wait with
a beard then you get a trilogy and and
so yes in it is probably not a causal
relationship it happens to be concurrent
maybe but the day after this Twitter
thread kind of blew up it was announced
that that these two guys are not doing a
Star Wars trilogy anymore what if that
was a coincidence just like it's been in
the works for like eight months press
release ready to go like push send and
then it just so happened to come that
would be the worst they had already sent
it to all the press but I'd listen you
couldn't the first thing Monday morning
embargo lifts did you see with it we
can't stop it we can't put this genie
back in the bottle
and so claiming that because they signed
a 250 million dollars to create TV shows
for them they were they were too busy to
then do Star Wars which is okay sure
because I thought money bought you time
I'd be pretty busy they were too busy to
do the last season of Game of Thrones
I'm weary I'm salty I'm folding
I'm felt that you're the another bag
that's fine I know I'm sorry I'm but yes
they are they are no longer doing a star
war or three star war were you excited
about the potential their Star Wars is
well I mean here I know the truth I felt
this way like I love Game of Thrones
like the first five seasons of Game of
Thrones first four magical the fifth is
really good and then how many seasons
are there eight there you go hey but
even still I was like you know what
those guys independent of anything else
I see how that choice makes sense right
like they told long-form story they
understood as far as we knew they aren't
like they understood the emotional
twists like yeah [ __ ] it give it to
those guys in the same way that giving
it to Jay Jay made sense of giving it
kid like Miller and Lord in the moment
makes sense like those [ __ ] guys
super smart I loved I loved the 21 Jump
Street movies yeah give them a movie
josh trank less so brian johnson sure
like i get that like brick is great
looper made a lot of money it's really
smart you like science fiction
give him a movie all of those things
discreetly in of themselves makes sense
the massive collection of that much
bearded white dude it became like okay
like is there nobody else who wants to
tell a story in this world there's a
nobody else who's got a Star Wars story
in them are there no women are there no
people of color
how'd you don't we let you out so like I
was like oh yeah sure I can see what
that movies would look like they're good
at long-form stories let's do this
but it's like lots of these decisions
just didn't seem to pan out the way that
I think Kathy Kennedy might have won
to not ferry think that she gets fired
over this because she's only really made
one giant mistake and that was solo
that's the one that cost them money
that's the one that cost them you know
they had to reshoot the movie it that
greatly spared no expense reassuring the
movie because she hired the wrong people
to do it and then she hired Ron Howard
who was fine
you know like aggressively fine like the
movie is emphatically okay but that is
her one big mistake it has still made
money it didn't lose money just wasn't
the hit they wanted it to be and I would
argue too that in theory Miller and Lord
for solo was brilliant Oh everyone says
that I would still watch that I know it
so I can find that cut cuz I'm sure
there's a miller and lord cut somewhere
like I will say that was the mood that
was the one I was most excited about
truly because I was like you know this
is the type of energy and this character
that I want to see that energy applied
like this makes perfect sense to me and
then an inventiveness and nerdery and
then I did not get to see that movie
yeah but so it's just like I want Kathy
Kennedy to widen her gaze a little bit
and I and I don't think she gets fired I
don't think she dis replaced I don't
know the person so but yeah it's it had
it all held promise until it didn't and
it just feels as if maybe going outside
of the box that Star Wars seems to have
built itself since 1977
which is you got to have a beard to make
one of these things I think Maureen Ryan
which at the time she was at the Tribune
maybe had grinded down the stats and of
every of all of the people who had ever
made a Star Wars movie above the line
there's one woman in 35 years Leigh
Brackett who co-wrote Empire Strikes
Back he's the only woman who's ever had
anything to do with a Star Wars movie
and like dad said something do you think
Lucasfilm would make the adaptation of
the George Lucas story where we find out
how much his wife contributed to the
Star Wars franchise
I'd like to see that movie is first way
Marshall Lucas yeah the Marshall Lucas
door I don't think that Lucas film is
gonna make that movie somebody else good
though yeah anyone listening yeah I bet
somebody wrote a book about her right
you can buy the rest of that book but
we've we've cracked it take it to fox
they'll make it oh damn we'll get to
that all right so that's that's the news
that we're gonna cover this week which
isn't a ton but it was juicy and
delicious so let's talk about a horror a
wimp
I do not cotton with horror
very much it wasn't always the case
like in growing up in the eighties it
was it was easier to be a horror fan I
think only in that a there was so much
of it most of it discovered on video on
VHS as one does but also the kinds of
horror you got
we're both wildly different and none of
it seemed like he was out to punish you
in a way that that some modern horror
felt like it was you know the there had
always been the manipulation the there
are going to be jump scares there's
going to be the thing that's a little
too gory but there was always this other
sense of we were trying to do more than
that even if we were ultimately gonna
it's like the broccoli is the rest of
the movie and the cheese is the jump
scares and together it's delicious but
like the plot and the character and all
of that [ __ ] has to work and we will
still give you all of these things you
want you're saying you feel like that
was her in the 80s I feel like that was
like 70s late 60s 70s 80s and then it
for me I stopped getting enjoyment out
of it in like the mid 2000 right because
of the quilt fingers torture poor and
kind of because you kind of food stuff
good Christian
I feel like that stuff is just like
Cheetos you know they're delicious mark
I know but there's little redeeming
value to a cheeto in the way there was
to cheese company I'm struggling with
this food SMI I went out on a limb but
yeah like the it turned a corner for me
I think the last the last couple of
horror movies I saw in the theater were
the ring which I liked the ring dreamy
but yeah the gore verbinski Naomi Watts
movie and and and Zack Snyder's Dawn of
the Dead and then I like kind of tried
hostel and it was like you know I saw
the trailers for saw was like [ __ ] you
and then just never really went back and
every now and again I'll rent something
because I keep being told man you gotta
watch hereditary you gotta watch so me
you gotta watch babadook oh yeah
definitely
and yet no I don't yes her have to watch
any of those are you saying you don't
like them or are you saying it's like
I'm uncomfortable or I'm scared okay and
it's like that's the same reason I love
rollercoasters you go on it's gonna be
scary you're missing out on the great
things in life don't you know the thrill
ride that's what it's for
you remember that you're alive when you
yes you know I can do that at like
fragility of human life on screen you
know what also achieves that
all-you-can-eat barbecue I might die to
the Chainsaw Massacre all in the
barbecue you need and I've seen that one
but it's like you know what I could eat
myself to death I'm pushing the edge I'm
living out there
this much brisket could kill a man
that's how I live on the edge so so tell
me how each of you came to harm what was
the first part of the song loved ooh
I watched way too many horror movies
when I was a kid my entire family loves
horror movie so this was like my bread
and butter it's the reason why I love
Stephen King the first movie that I
think that I saw that we rented that I
was terrified of was Nightmare on Elm
Street and just the just the idea that
you cannot go to sleep it just messed my
brain up I remember keeping my eyes open
or I tried to all night just in case
Freddy was like gonna come and jump out
I was terrified but I remembered more
than anything the soundtrack of that
movie it was like one two Freddy's
coming for you and I was like oh like
that song was stuck in my head and it
just stuck with me and so I just became
addicted to horror films you would think
you would have the opposite effects
where I would be like no I don't want to
see this anymore I was like oh I was
totally terrified yeah let's do it again
alright for me I was definitely like a
scared kid for sure I always was
attracted to you know dark fantasy so I
loved Tim Burton and I loved Legend and
labyrinth and Willow and all these like
eighties things and then and then I a
babysitter actually showed me the
Stephen King's it miniseries when I was
like 5 and I was wrecked and then I was
at a friend's house for Halloween when I
was about 12 and we watched The Exorcist
and like you were saying with the sound
yes like I covered my eyes but it's
still here everything and I had seen
enough to where my brain created I mean
I am not exaggerating when I say I did
not sleep for a year yeah after I saw
that movie
child I actually figured out I think the
trick is covering your ears close your
eyes but if you can still hear what's
happening at mine filters indeed if I
could go back and tell twelve-year-old
Clarke exactly this I'm imagining 12
year old car going yeah so it was
definitely scarred it's truely and you
know it was interesting too is for me it
wasn't a wasn't like I was brought up
Catholic and it was or you know there
was any sort of implication there except
that this movie was tariffs and it's and
also so now as an adult I have it's one
of my favorite movies of all time and
and and I think it is absolutely
brilliant and I think it's about so much
more than just the scares and the and
the incredible makeups and all of that
but it was in high school when I started
like I took a film class in high school
and I really started going oh horror has
something to say and that's when it
started and also because I was less
scared so I could like to actually make
it through a real scary movie without
losing sleep but um yeah when I and then
in college I studied horror academically
so really focusing on political
commentary and horror and science
fiction and which is why I want to talk
more about this the hostels of it all
but we'll get to that I actually had
very similar experiences to both of you
in that I was a scared kid horror movie
scared me so badly because I used to
watch them with my dad you know who
would put on the original Halloween and
I could hear this the music and just
like it would haunt my dreams yeah my
dad loved scaring me he also loved
watching his favorite comedy show to
watch in the 90s was cops enjoy scaring
me by watch by putting on scary movies
but also I was like a very shy fantasy
nerd
and so fantasy became an adjacent way in
I read a lot of books about dragons when
I was a young girl and as I got older
that morbid fascination I think turned
into you know something more like I was
more interested in how it works in more
interested in and watching different
kinds of genres stuff and I never
studied horror movies in college
although that sounds awesome it was fun
yeah III have a similar experience to
both of you in that I remember watching
The Exorcist that must have been like 16
years old and and I was like how scary
could this movie be it's as old as I am
oh nothing old is good whatever 16 year
old movies [ __ ] and was like hiding
behind a couch for most of it because
it's petrifying and and night random
street is the one that stuck with me the
most because it's the thing that I
always responded to was less the scares
and more the here's why you can't escape
it right like it becomes it becomes a a
not quite plot exercise but it's the
high concept of why is this let me find
a thing that you can't get rid of that's
an inherently human that you can't get
rid of that literally everyone everybody
does
you have to sleep it's making later it's
making it Universal and so it was always
less about the here's a slasher who's
coming out of this lake and it's gonna
kill he's a bunch of kids that never
felt universal to me despite the fact
that I used to camp but the everybody
goes to sleep yeah you know everybody's
got a kid or a sibling who's acting
funny
you know like for that one's like the
[ __ ] is wrong with him I don't know
could be possessed really no that was a
fan
everybody stayed at a hotel that seemed
a little dodgy you know like it's
finding those the specificity and
universality which is the thing that
that as storytellers we're always
looking for right here
that the thing that makes it specific
and that specific is the thing that we
can all respond to and and and and key
ourselves into and as Haru began at
least modern heart for me never gave me
that thing
it seemed always about the sensation of
you just want to be scared and people
who get pleasure out of that that's for
them but it never engaged me in a in a
sort of mentally plot-wise like there
was one level ever that was ever working
for me I think you should watch
hereditary what do you guys think yeah
hereditary sentence how dysfunctional
was your family yeah about as much as
anybody
yeah probably true okay so we all we all
took it upon ourselves we wanted to talk
about three movies three horror movies
that mean things to us and and and we
wanted to talk about why they mean
things to us why we responded to them
over other ones so Jenn you go first
[Laughter]
you wrote all these ladies have notes
just winging it oh wow nice I feel
inadequate is that a unicorn no what's
on the front Ragan it's a bird
sorry the wings and the beak threw me my
bad um I wanted to take you back to the
old school older than there's a Japanese
movie called Carone echo which
translates the black cat which is from
1968 and what I find really fascinating
about
which i think is some criteria is and
it's like beautiful beautiful haunting
imagery it's based on sort of Japanese
folklore about two women who are
brutally attacked killed brought back to
life in a way by a black cat that licks
at their bodies and they're brought back
is like avenging cat ladies which is
awesome but also what I find fascinating
about that is fast forward to oh I guess
not fast Ford you go across the world to
wit to 1942 and you have cat people
produced by Val Lewton you have cat
people sequel or not sequel remake that
called cat people we're just a little
bit different change the story a little
bit and then josh akin scheming that's
right it's a 61 mm with a Giorgio
Moroder theme so good um and then you
have of course the Halle Berry classic
Catwoman this you know we will get
that's Universal Pictures major motion
picture cat this holiday season note
that sherry in that trailer I remain
unconvinced that that's an actual movie
and not just an elaborate prank yes do
you like how they drop that one trailer
at comic-con and then have you seen
anything else from cats and no only in
my yeah exactly in our hearts and in her
tree so I can't wait so this thread is
like cats are evil clearly oh I guess
where I'm going with this is it's
interesting to me how cross cultures and
cross generations you can have kind of
similar seats of a story with centered
around this kind of figure in all of
these stories they're women who turned
into scary cats but they have they have
their reasons they have their reasons
and I
it was kind of interesting to to place
those all in counterpoint to one another
including Halle Berry
where she was also linked by a bunch of
cats and dad with the superpowers of
engines I mean the math checks out
secretly hope that is this one day I I
need this to happen my cats not going to
come do that to me like I
that's why I have a black cat you know
like just in case none of the cat in the
carnations yes I need the cat people
marathon Alamo Drafthouse cat people
Mary ting up to the premiere of cats
okay that's where I stopped out hey yo I
had a great idea I want all the credit
no Clark don't tell us the movies right
so for those of you listening and
watching there was a lot of back and
forth on this first one I texted mark
and then I was like I'm changing my
movie and then I'm back in the back we
were talking about it and I was like I'm
changing it back so I'm gonna go
poltergeist the original um yes and III
think it's important to talk about this
movie for a lot of reasons you'll notice
that two of my three choices tonight are
rather basic and I accept that but I do
think that there's something really
important in genre and horror
specifically that resonates with people
and that has like not you know it's not
just horror fans that are into this like
it definitely touches on something
within like the broader picture and
poltergeist I loved for many many
reasons but the biggest reasons for me
is Jobeth Williams Diane Freeling is one
of the best characters best moms in
horror movies ever and I don't mean like
what a good mom I just mean like what a
fascinating interesting character she's
a fighter she's so but what else I love
about it is that it's a movie
where the the the mom is at the center
of the story so like if you look at
something like say insidious which i
think is kind of like a very loose
poltergeist remake which I love I love
the first tunes I love a lot of them
insidious movies but the first two are
fun for different reasons but they've
essentially switched the roles so
Patrick Wilson becomes like the focal
point of the story whereas if you look
at the og it actually is diet it's Diane
Jo Beth is actually build above Craig T
Nelson which you never see it anymore
like you never see I guess when I guess
when it comes to like a two-parent
household depicted in a movie it's
usually the dad who's like doing the
fighting right and and in this one we
are exploring so much like if you pick
up on the fact that Diane was 16 when
she had her oldest daughter and now
Craig T Nelson has become this like
capitalist you know successful guy and
obviously that comes with a horrible
horrible horrible price I also think the
movie is super heartfelt I think it is
emotional like I think it's an emotional
scary movie which i think is doesn't
it's hard to do it's hard to pull off
the sincerity of like feeling especially
when we're talking about the
supernatural like the idea that Diane
and the female paranormal investigator
have this really beautiful quiet
conversation about what a soul is and
what happens when you die and what you
believe it's like as a poet and of
course they get scared later like that
happens but like it's it's just such a
powerful concept to me I think this
movie is it stands the test of time it
has a lot to say and on the you know
lore and legacy of the tobe Hooper
versus the Steven Spielberg of it all
like you know I used to go back and
forth on it what I think is a fan and
knowing both of their visual styles but
I know that there are a lot of people
especially since Toby has passed away
that that you know adamantly say not
only was did Toby direct
that movie but like they're kind of
furious that the cast has some of the
cast has let this rumor grow and grow
and grow and and so I I think it's fair
to give Toby the credit for making the
movie that's what I think also what you
got um so I should just stay with
Nightmare on Elm Street because we
talked about it a little bit but I think
my favorite thing about that movie is
Nancy the character of Nancy Heather
Langenkamp is so so good
she's like a survivor she's scared she
has a boyfriend who gets eaten up by a
bed I mean like it's just really really
a great journey for her well my favorite
part is that she fights back right so
she creates all these traps at the end
of the movie and she's not just gonna go
down like most girls and movies do she's
not gonna become a victim and I always
liked that she fought back I mean
there's really great deaths in my Roma
Street so you can't go wrong with that
but that's truly the reason why I like
it alright I am going to my first pick
is a film by Karyn Kusama
called the invitation which is it's a
it's a small movie it's it's a movie
that for her comes on the heels of
having made a giant movie that nobody
gave a [ __ ] about called Aeon Flux which
was a disaster by any sort of by any
measure in Hollywood the reviews are bad
it costs a lot of money it didn't make
anything back the hair was really I mean
the costumes are kind of great was with
sharp and Charlize Theron is doing a
thing as she always does but it landed
with a thud and she got put in a
director jail as some directors when
they make one big bad movie end up it
especially if you're a woman or a person
of color making a studio movie where you
don't have full control right so it took
her forever to kind of like you get back
on her feet and find her her way back
into the system back into behind the
director's chair and one of those first
waves back was this movie called the
invitation which is tiny it maybe cost
like four five million dollars max
and it's mostly set in this in this
house up in the Hollywood Hills and
you're following this couple as they
drive up his garden path they're going
to this party that they don't want to be
at and very slowly he start to unravel
that like the guy had been in a
relationship with a woman throwing the
party who had been gone for a while
internationally and then she's back but
she brought this other boyfriend who's
super [ __ ] weird and like his you
know girlfriend who's kind of on board
because she doesn't understand the
entire contours of all these
relationships but it's a movie that is
I'm not gonna spoil it because the end
of this movie is fantastic but you know
how you're in a horror movie and you're
always second-guessing the characters
were you like you know if you were just
left now everything would have been fine
if you just picked up a knife and stab
them in the head dude it'll all been
good this is a movie that anticipates
every time you want a character to leave
and it gives you a compelling reason for
that character to stay so you're never
in that sense of I'm it's it's straining
my believability that these are human
people responding to actual human
stimuli it leads you down that trail and
lets you understand every reason why
every character is doing everything as
smart or dumb or as Daffy where's the
violent as they might ultimately be and
it's a and when you get to the end of it
and when it finally reveals itself as to
what it is it's wonderful because you've
been down that road because you've made
every bad decision with these guys and
with these ladies for the reasons why
that it's [ __ ] awesome
how have you guys here seen it the
invitation - I'm pretty sure it's still
streaming on Netflix it's on Netflix
also I mean there's a movie to mention
between the and flux and the invitation
at Karma kusama directed and that's
Jennifer's body getting a lot of love
was very Malayan at the time
in 2009 Congress Alma and late Vox Megan
Fox who's one of the two stars of
Jennifer's body recently did a really
great Q&A and sort of Reclamation
screening I would probably describe it
up at the Egyptian epyon fest and talked
about what that process is like in what
enduring that was like and and sort of
how much misogyny we probably most of us
never realized was thrown at them during
the process of making and releasing that
film so I think that's also one that's
way too short
revisiting yeah like the invitation was
when you were in the room for the first
season of Castle Rock that was one of
our kind of signals like how do we put
characters and uncomfortable and
possible situations in ways that make
sense and feel logical not just plot
wise but emotionally because if you
don't have that emotional context then
it's all just moves it's all just people
are doing things because the script told
them to do those things but getting
inside those characters and knowing why
they do the things they do it's kind of
one of the things we took them back I
feel like that was kind of a cheat
though is it really horror it's kind of
like I guess thriller suspense maybe we
got jump scares it gets gory are they
gonna give you a pass on how and shadows
who Jordan coochie Ola from vulture who
put together that screening at the
Egyptian and and there's a great
write-up of the conversation that she
had with with Karan and Jennifer and I'm
really arms Jennifer I the one with the
body but I'm really glad cuz I had to go
to a bridal shower it won't long so I
didn't get to go I had tickets and I
couldn't go so reading it was like
really enlightening and I'm really glad
that that vulture ran it as a piece
what's your second movie Clark oh me oh
okay we've gone around the horn
alright so this is the one that I took
the most notes for because I wanted to
make sure I got some stuff right um I of
course want to get the other stuff right
too
this is one in particular so there's a
movie that came out in 1999 from
director Antonia bird called ravenous
has anybody seen ravenous yeah okay
great you're doing the Lord's work
trying to tell people about ravenous
your favorite cannibal Wendigo movie
okay so yes that's right so okay
ravenous is a very very dark comedy and
and horror movie starring Guy Pearce and
Robert Carlyle and I gotta say by the
way I was rematching this movie and I
was like hello Robert Carlyle I don't
know why this was the one and not like
The Full Monty exactly but this was the
one for me it says something about my
tastes but anyway so I love this movie
so much and this was a movie that came
out and n was miss marketed and
definitely like kind of speaking of
landed with a thud like absolutely
landed with a thud
Antonia bird who has since passed away
she actually was not the original
director on this movie the original
director was fired two weeks into
production and it actually was Robert
Carlyle who was like I've worked with
her many many times in the UK and I
think that you guys should should hire
her and what came out of this was just
like I love this movie so much it almost
feels like Coen Brothers adjacent like
that very dark grim bloody violent very
funny in a lot of ways look at humanity
and so this also plays off of the
Wendigo or wendi-go however you choose
to pronounce it lore folklore that is
prominent up in in the Great Lakes of
Canada and the US and I wanted to tell
you guys about this because and this is
the part that's really important I think
so this this creature in folklore
possesses the the human person and they
have to eat human flesh and they they
cannot be sustained and they almost like
get superpowers yeah eat up
hey that was a great time take a bite of
a top right are they tossed are they
fingers but and they're hot it's okay
put some ketchup on it but anyway so
they it not only you you cannot satiate
this hunger but you almost you get
stronger you your senses act you know it
get get more you know sharp and also
win-win it's a win-win D go okay so I
wanted to bring this up though because
dad jokes I I listen to this podcast and
it's called pleasing terrors and if you
guys are into like genre folklore horror
stories ghost stories but fact that is
sort of built into this too I cannot
recommend it enough
but one of my favorite episodes is
actually called hungry spirits and they
talked about this and I told mark this
at dinner and I just think it's such a
cool fact this is what a nerd I am okay
so the wendi-go myth and folklore has
has been sort of present in cult this
culture these cultures for hundreds and
hundreds of years right but as time
progressed the evolution of this
folklore progressed as well and in the
early 1900's it would became known as
Wendigo psychosis right so it's a thing
it's a clinical thing that people
recognize and again specific to the
Great Lakes of Canada and the US okay
it's disappeared
you guys like meaning there is no known
instance of Wendigo psychosis in living
memory that we know well but that's the
thing is that like these reports aren't
happening like if people aren't being
treated for it and I find that so
fascinating because it's like what was
in the water what was happening to these
human brains that was causing this but
now just like isn't there it's so cool
when you think about that I'm so nerdy
this is I'm so sweaty right now dude and
like Saskatchewan was like oh yeah what
and then now we're talking about it and
gonna like yeah Winnebago are you saying
you want to manifest the return of the
Windigo no no I definitely don't but
anyway this movie is great guy Pierce is
amazing in it and as is Robert as is the
whole supporting cast and I do think
that from the score to the tone to the
humor to the action sequences like she
and Tony a bird directed the [ __ ] out of
this movie and and I wish more people
saw it mark have you seen it no Clark do
you think mark can handle it I do I
really really like I also love that you
almost said direct the [ __ ] out of it
and then you pivoted to [ __ ] I did like
I don't want to go excitedly like geeked
out over people eating each other I know
I made it pg-13 I did I tried notes um
the other thing is we were talking about
this earlier bad news friends this is a
fox mm movie so if you're concerned
about not being able to find things
because the overlords are putting them
in the vaults you just might want to buy
it on blu-ray there was actually an
awesome blu-ray release that happened a
few years ago or get it get it while you
can cause your friends burn away she
added the DVD
mailing feature back on to her Netflix
for precisely this reason yep they're
just movies that aren't streaming and
may never be streaming and like there
are still physical media wait that's an
option did not but in the u.s. ravenous
is streaming on Hulu and the blu-ray is
really good so that's my two cents
excellent our area from my schpeel
round to what you got I'm gonna take it
back to the 90s what's in the rainbow
book do you remember the 90s do you
remember the year 1992 that's what we
call 90s no oh you you like blacked it
out of the membrane
I don't blame you a little movie called
Pet Sematary - - Wow - oh DOS
sorry - is my preferred Pet Sematary
both one and two are directed by the
great Mary Lambert but two is the one
that starred Eddie furlong who had such
a run in a very specific period I'm
talking three that I'm talking like 92
93 94 great wait what's on it especially
for heart Pet Sematary 292 after Pet
Sematary - he did oh wait before the
year before he did Terminator 2 Judgment
Day and then the year after he made the
living on the edge music video by arrows
oh wow yeah my Eddie furlong crush was
extreme at the time I sat right behind
him at the giant Silent Bob movie
premiere and like I didn't recognize him
at first until he turned John Connor
living the dream what brought him to
that premiere Tuesday an invitation I'm
not entirely sure he may or may not have
been in the movie I can't say because I
was waiting from my cameo not his and
then 1994 brought his brain scan what
happened after that I am not quite sure
what happened after that but those few
years were so rich they really ready for
a long miss in Pet Sematary - isn't
Clancy Brown and that one yeah I think I
just watched this like a year ago for
the first time but I don't know if I
finished it Wow I was in a hotel let's
watch that again put it on the list but
I know
list okay I'm watching my oven is there
a dead cat in this one - oh wow we kept
me at that so it's in the first one sure
she I'm sensing a theme alright anyway
my turn sir numero dos numero dos okay
so this little movie called midsummer ah
or as I like to call it at midsummer I
don't know why the a it just confuses me
so I just add the accent um guys I just
saw this a few days ago
and I'm not recovered yet
okay I I was so scared to watch it first
of all I haven't seen heredity so
because I was already too scared and I
gathered all my strength and I rented
midsummer and my god I don't want to
give too many spoilers but I'll just say
something horrific happens in the first
act
this is kind of like before the story
kind of begins and you're led into this
story by this young woman the
character's name is Danny played by
Florence Hugh I think her name is and
who is phenomenal absolutely I hadn't
seen her before and so I looked up her
credits and I seen her in this movie
Lady Macbeth
which can years ago and she was
phenomenal in that um but so for
whatever reason these this group of
friends from college decides oh yeah
let's go to this like Festival in like
some Nordic place and guys bad things
happened bad bad things
how many people here have made summer
midsummer oh my god
how are you I'm still standing after
having watched it oh my god so horrible
things first of all this is all I have
to say I was shocked that there were
black people in this movie I was like
hear that right now I was like there was
one black person and for whatever reason
he was not listening to his ancestors
because he should have got the hell up
out of there with a quickness because
I'm just saying like an hour into this
movie which is the other thing you need
to know it's kind of a slow-moving film
so it's very beautiful it's very lush re
esters great director so he really sets
the tone for the film but like an hour
into some shenanigans happened that I
won't spoil and I'm sorry where are the
cars because I would have been gone and
so the fact that the black man stayed
after this happened I was like I'm not
buying this so that's my my one caveat
let's let's be thankful that he survived
an hour into the movie yes this is this
is show he could have been gone in like
the first two minutes so you are you're
correct but I mean aside from the
cinematography in this film is
incredible it's so beautiful the places
that they go are wonderful you get a
kind of psychedelic feel because there's
a lot of drug taking not for these
mushrooms and I'm just like what are
y'all doing you just arrived in the
strange place and you're imbibing drugs
like what is happening like I don't know
all my instincts were like on eleven so
I was ready I was just I'm all ready
who's ready to run and so and then like
I say the shenanigans happen people
still stay people start disappearing
people still stay and I won't swear thin
but holy jesus the ending is batshit
crazy and please watch it without
spoiling
that is amazing I also think it's a
great entry in relationship horror yes
my god she the worst relationship quick
little thing I was I was I don't get
invited to any cool Hollywood things and
I did get invited to see to the small LA
premiere of midsummer couldn't go cuz my
boyfriend and I were breaking up oh this
is a breakup movie ah
that's even better like I cancelled my I
really sorry I can't make it I'm sick no
I was breaking up on my date and then I
saw the movie later and I was like aha
that's awesome okay I i've already since
this year's Halloween is forever long
and I've been to God knows how many
parties already it's not even it's not
even tomorrow it's the day after
tomorrow
officially I've seen so many midsummer
oh yeah because it's very beautiful why
it's so scary it's so pretty
glory I won't say what it is but the
couples costume version of that oh God
it's great I know like a running is this
too scary the running tally of [ __ ] I
won't see yeah that's on it yeah I won't
say that it's it's not as scary as I've
heard hereditary is so yeah even I and
I'm a horrible I couldn't go that was a
bridge too far so that's all you're
gonna see the extended director's cut
it's already almost two and a half hours
it's dumb uh-uh
no well you should have put it in the
beginning I can't sit for the director's
cut what is your ideal runtime hour and
a half only five minutes yeah I 100 on a
good day I was thinking about how we
don't have enough or almost any kid
horror anymore are you afraid of the
dark
except for are you afraid of the dark
Nickelodeon's reboot three really series
it is really good really good highly
yeah collodion brought it back
speaking of kid hearts not quick hit
hard but I'm calling an audible
my second my second was going to be
trained from Busan train - it's such a
movie and I love that it's it's it is a
zombie movie through and through but the
thing that makes it different is that
it's shot through the cultural lens of
South Korea and what what that society
and how that society treats a thing like
a zombie outbreak it's fascinating it's
[ __ ] scary and it's gory and I can
live with it kazaaam B's I can somewhat
roll with him the way that [ __ ] another
thing it's things I can't but I'm
calling an audible because I remember
taking my son - they did a rerelease
like three or four years ago maybe a
little older of ghostbusters and I
realized he didn't get any of the jokes
because he's 12 and if you strip out all
of the humor from ghostbusters it is a
really effective supernatural horror
movie all of the [ __ ] beats work all
of the go shit's work all of the jump
scares work
everything is eerie and spooky and why
is that lady hovering over there what is
this key masters [ __ ] one of these
rubber dogs doing I don't know it all
seems awful like it he was petrified and
I just I had never reckoned with that
movie in that way before
but it's the reason why it works is
because at its core if you're gonna do a
movie a comedy version of an actual
thing it needs to be the good version of
that thing first
like Young Frankenstein works because
it's actually a really strong
Frankenstein movie that has jokes so
like all of the structure works all of
the horror works all of those beats
function is actual drama and then
there's jokes and I was I was kind of
blown away by that like I'd never
realized that before the reason I love
Ghostbusters it's not because it's funny
which it is and not because to the cast
which is amazing that they are but it's
it is actually a really good
supernatural movie in defiance of the
rest of that stuff and every other time
you see a movie like that that doesn't
do that work like say the new
Ghostbusters movie which I have nothing
against it but it doesn't work as a
supernatural horror film
it is just a comedy and some of the
comedy is funny but it's not doing the
thing you need that movie to do which is
deliver scares every 15 minutes until
you pass out and then scares every half
an hour after that that too is Dan
Aykroyd Ackroyd's a huge like
supernatural enthusiast you follow just
like he's in it yes in that [ __ ] like
you believe the apocalypse is coming
because the movie is teaching you how
that apocalypse she really does y'all
and it doesn't get any scarier than the
Stay Puft Marshmallow Man no just saying
shall is brilliant I thought it was
great and like that's the part that I
think got my son the most but yeah shows
up like I don't like this at all day
Ghostbusters too when I was a kid my
parents took me to see I think they
thought I was too young to let any of it
register oh ohoh Vigo the Carpathian
coming out of that wall out of that
painting no no baby Clark was not having
that mom and dad regretted that decision
a real I think is what Vigo remains one
of the scariest islands that I see I
actually like Ghostbusters - I'm sorry I
know we've we've shifted public opinion
then it's a safe space Oliver Oliver
friend I have a question do you go do I
believe in ghosts yes whoo
because I lived in an apartment in
Queens that I'm positive was [ __ ]
haunted how do you know what would
happen because I remember being in that
apartment and my then girlfriend hated
it because she was convinced that the
ghosts didn't like her in the house and
so she'd be like I got up and this [ __ ]
face staring back at me in the mirror
it's not my face I I was walking down
and like Sunday and there's no windows
blowing yeah it's like I but I didn't
see I was like
I see one wrong move I hear one noise
upstairs I am out for air
i I don't believe in ghosts in the like
religious sense because I'm a godless
heathen but I believe that energy needs
a place to go and sometimes set energy
has blocks that stop it from going
wherever it's supposed to totally I
think you believed your girlfriend at
the time yeah I mean I didn't move but I
believe I treat ghosts the same way I
treat like spiders which is like listen
don't come in my space if you stay in
your side of it good come here that we
have a problem so the ghost was never up
in my grill says like hey man you go
haunt that [ __ ] do it
alright so last what's your me again
alright okay so to continue my two out
of three basic recommendations um mine
is is 2013 the conjuring now this is a
yes thank you
yep this is a franchise that you all
have heard of I'm sure because we cannot
escape nuns and Annabelle's and off of
things it is taken over the world and in
a way I think that's cool but I do want
to say that the conjuring I believe is
like a horror masterpiece the first
movie I mean because it works on the
simplest levels it is a family melodrama
and and and so James Wan has ruined
haunted house movies forever because the
conjuring actually when you when a
jump-scare is what kicks something off
it actually kicks something off it's
shot like an action sequence which is so
awesome like when you watch that movie
there are no cheap jump scares and I
think that when we especially this time
of year everybody writes an article
about jump scares boo
we hate them whatever and that's totally
fair when they don't lead to something
right because you're as an oddity like
Steven Spielberg talks about in Jaws the
the head that pops up in Ben Gardner's
boat and he's like they added that later
and usually like before they added that
the shark jumping out of the water onto
the Orca was the one where the audience
would like lose their [ __ ] and when they
added Ben Gardner's boat this Spielberg
was like what happened they're not
jumping like when the shark jumps out of
the water and it's like yeah cuz you
already gotta you know you build up that
goodwill with the audience and you can
use it once and then once you get them
they're gonna be suspicious of you for
the rest of the movie so I get why
people are annoyed with jump scares but
the conjuring like every sigh just
re-watched it again every every scare
leads to another scare leads to
something that feels satisfying and I
remember I went and saw the movie
Winchester because I had starring Helen
Mary absolutely first of all you have to
say Helen Mirren is a G she okay sorry
about the girl yeah le goddess that is
Helen Mirren but I say that because you
know actually I thought Winchester had a
great premise the execution was not
great but the point is I act that was
the moment where I realized that James
Wan ruined everything forever because
you can't do cheap anymore
now audiences like they almost expect a
little bit more and frankly it's kind of
a reason why I'm a little disappointed
in the overall conjuring franchise
because they didn't follow James it's
like they learned all the wrong lessons
from you first country movie but anyway
ready for conjuring 3 I'll be there and
the first one really really really is
great so if you're looking for something
that Oh
last thing sorry this this is my time of
year you guys I'm so excited
what's on
but um so the the myth or the rumor like
conjuring is rated R and the the method
of the room we was always like we
couldn't figure out why we got in our
rating because there's nothing in this
movie there's no blood there's no sex
there's no profanity and that's actually
true the I I asked Peter Safran one of
the producers like it's not just
something y'all made up and he was like
no we thought we were making a pg-13
movie we just kept going back to the
MPAA what can we cut what can we what
can we do and they're like oh nothing
it's too scary like well guess we're
making an r-rated movie then and now all
of them have to be art but the point is
if you have a friend you like you're
into horror and they want to watch
something that's kind of scary but
that's actually good i I think conjuring
is a great gateway movie I agree is that
your favorite haunted house movie it's
that's a great question just poltergeist
account oh okay I guess I count I like
when you we were talking all I kept
thinking about was the others yes I
loved the other I love that movie so
much and it is so well done and I
recently watched it and it still holds
that it's still really really on point
understand my reference that is a great
I know it's a really a perfect agreed it
holds up but anyway the conjuring like
really check it out the other ones are
fine but this one is something special
all right and rent
what you got Jade out what's in the book
of runners talk about vampires you guys
we haven't done vampires yeah and by
vampires I mean the John Carpenter movie
vampires from 1909
no they were 'saying boo I'm really
curious guy who boot why why boo oh wow
loving daddy James try to kill vampires
very good at his job
okay changed wouldn't have Jon Bon Jovi
in it there are there are two sequels
vampire what that is too many sequels to
him John Carpenter's more vampires
vampires is really fun and it got me
thinking what why were the late the mid
to late nineties so obsessed with
vampires
great question sexy because they're sexy
hot except with a vampire like the book
came out and then the movie came out and
was like Brad Pitt was looking to mostly
seems to like these vampires but like
the 90s they're like totally 90s vampire
movies they're not like interview as
vampire no they're like what's that so
it's like interview Catherine Deneuve
and Susan tiger I mean remembers but
also I was thinking more along lines of
from dusk till dawn yeah that's a good I
like that one and Sam year is John
Carpenter's vampire's blade came out
hey why are we into vampires I don't
know but you know I was thinking in
terms of news as you want to to cover on
this program occasionally but I was
still from the Internet
in the great Marvel vs. auteur Wars what
greater you know common ground is there
than Bram Stoker's Dracula meets blade
just have a double feature guys and work
it all or well that's yes I support
Coppola to direct blade or that okay
sure what uh-oh no I do not want to see
that movie handle either of those things
well don't I
never seen Cotton Club he's really great
with African America this is the word
episode are we gonna talk about Jeepers
Creepers no I'm here we go that one
[ __ ] cover
I just one more vampire in Brooklyn love
oh yeah Eddie story about that yeah
asked Angela Bassett about that because
Wes had just passed and she just was
like well first of all Angela Bassett is
she's just a like wonderful and
beautiful and amazing and talented and
but she she had the most lovely lovely
lovely things to say because I think
that notoriously that was a bit of a
contentious set because Wes wanted to
make a scary like I'm sorry Wes wanted
to make a comedy and Eddie wanted to
make a scary movie and they were not on
board but Angela Bassett said that she
she loved being with both of them and
and that she loved working with Wes and
I thought that was really a guy that
wanted to get paid whatever movie you
guys want to make her rolling cameras
I'm showing up but she's so good anyway
all right so John Carter's vampires Dr
you have you extolled the virtues of
said thing about wait so much sadder
blade that's all all right cool has
anyone here seen Full Tilt boogie the
behind the scenes documentary that is oh
one of my favorite like filmmaking
documentaries that's room from dusk till
dawn but I wonder as filmmakers
creatives
what do you guys almost want to know
from these
how they were made I kind of I love the
like evil dead - it's the how we got it
done
it's the we're trying to do something
interesting and new and different we
have no money we have no time it is
nothing but ingenuity and
spit-and-polish and gumption and like
[ __ ] it we can't ever state again how do
we do this well it turns out if we take
a giant plank of wood and screw the
camera to the middle and like each of us
hold it it'll kind of steady it enough
that is not crazy
oh [ __ ] never thought of that you know
like I love that story from the set of
The Terminator where they're trying to
do
Arnold punching through the glass of the
of the car or like listen we the only
way for us to do this effectively is for
us to put an actual like pneumatic
cannon in where his arm should be and
that is what's gonna punch through but
we can't mount that on the car and then
have Arnold there and a safety thing and
some grip was like what if we just moved
the bricks in the back of the car it'll
look like the cars moving it's like yes
that thing it's it's the it's the
solving problems in ways when you don't
have money to solve those problems or CG
or C like it's either in the script or
it's just like [ __ ] it we're Boy Scouts
today let's make this [ __ ] up no I do I
love knowing the behind the scenes of
how people make things but the thing
that always interests me as someone who
is always trying to come up with ideas
is like the inspiration and so I really
liked when Wes Craven talks about how he
got the idea for Nightmare on Elm Street
and I was like holy [ __ ] this was
inspired by some real things that
happened where there were people who
were complaining that they were having
these nightmares and they would they
would find that they had a coffee pot
hidden in their room and they were
trying to stay up for days on end and
they wouldn't mysteriously died and I
was like that's a great idea for a story
because you've always heard that sort of
myth of if you die in your sleep you're
gonna die in real
and so I just love stuff like that where
you get to marry the thing that they
found interesting and that became the
kernel of the idea of the film
do you have crazy dreams like movie
dreams that you turn into ideas oh all
the time
all the time that it happens and I
actually keep a journal next to my bed
and I write down the dreams because
sometimes I'm like that I don't know how
that's gonna become a story idea but I'm
just gonna record it and that time when
you're like searching for ideas you have
a reservoir right there for you I
haven't remembered a dream in like 20
years
oh my god really I never remember my
dreams okay I remember all the time some
of them are scary it's like I've there's
been times when I've had a like a sad
dream and I've awakened myself crying
I've had scary dreams where I just wake
up heart pounding like oh my god thank
God that was a dream so there I feel
like it was really visceral things that
are coming to you that are trying to
inspire you to you can use them in your
art humanity sounds awful humanity is
beautiful be a robot it's you you know
why we have movies to process the scary
movies help this process yeah
alright Latoya what's your last one
what's your guy my last one is a fun
women it's interesting that we were
talking about mixing comedy and horror
because my last recommendation for you
and I know you've all seen this is
attack the block which is from a few
years ago it's so so good it is kind of
a cheap because it's a it's kind of more
sci-fi but it is horror about an alien
invasion that happens in this urban area
I think Brixton in London and it's the
first time that I ever saw John boyega
and I was absolutely blown away he was
like Will Smith's mixed with Denzel
Washington all in one he was phenomenal
and the story it was the first time I've
really seen a horror movie where I felt
like oh that could happen to me I
be in this movie like yes some [ __ ]
aliens come to my neighborhood you all
fight them off
yes that's my kind of movie and so I
think Joe Cornish directed in it was his
first movie and he did a really great
thing which was he tried to ground it in
everything practical and so there were
like the puppets though of aliens were
puppets instead of like being CG and
they really like ran down those hallways
like really fast for all the action
sequences so he really tried to make a
big high concept movie for a very small
price and I think that is a lost art
nowadays and it's a really great movie
because of it it's 89 minutes long yes
perfectly perfectly was there not
recently a screening of it they invited
me to present a movie of my choice and I
chose to check the block smart man many
of the reasons that Latoya yes it is
phenomenal and it's always interesting
to see the unlikeliest heroes yes be the
ones you who saved the day and there are
a few or unlikely heroes that a bunch of
street thugs from the UK yeah the block
and it's surprising too one of my
favorite scenes in the film is like
towards the end they have to sneak and
they have to go back to Moses john
boyega's house and so they've done like
they've robbed people and done all kinds
of horrible bad [ __ ] but you go to this
kid's house and he has superheroes
sheets on his bed he's still a kid he's
just a baby and so you really get that
it's just a small moment where he's
really humanized he's more than just the
thug that they exactly yeah alright for
my for my last for my last choice from
my third and final I am choosing a film
that seemed like it came out 15 years
ago but it turns out was like just
[ __ ] February Jordan peels us
or to be more precise half of Jordan
peels
Jordan peels us begins as this sort of
like it's it's a portrait into this
family they're going on vacation and
everything feels weighted and leaded
with dread like every moment of that
movie is just dripping with something is
going to happen like Jordan Peele he's
he is so in control of his craft that he
understands how to build tension out of
what seems like it's gonna be normal
he understands how to make you think
that a monster or whatever bad [ __ ] is
gonna happen to this family at any
moment and when it does it's harrowing
and if you haven't seen the movie
towards the trailers for the movie this
family of four lupita you know [ __ ]
giant thighs Winston dude it's like
candy thighs Winston Duke and then there
was a dude in the last room that I was
in who I don't know if he was gay before
he saw Black Panther but then he was
like when that when he's just sitting
there he's [ __ ] like his legs just
straddle is like you got vegetarians
he's like I think it moved so I'm like
they're the parents and they've got
these two kids and and what happens is
it's a home invasion and the people who
were invading this home are weird ass
doppelgangers of those people and it's
frightening as [ __ ] like the the home
invasion itself is incredibly well done
and the idea that you're being hunted by
yourself and itself that is not from
this world but someplace else is it the
self especially when you're dealing with
with African Americans who have achieved
some semblance of success in the world
there's always a version of yourself you
had to leave behind to achieve that
there's always some element over here's
where I grew up here's the family use to
have here's the cousins used to play
with whatever that is there's they you
have to or the the myth that you have to
transcend that in order to become a
success who are we leaving behind when
we
do that and and there's a version of
that movie that that's what it's about
it is about being invaded by the version
yourself you have to leave behind and
then the movie goes to another house and
in that other house Elizabeth moss and
her husband and their shitty-ass kids
are in there also being hunted by
doppelgangers of themselves then you're
like but why like why does it need to be
bigger than this why can't it just be a
home invasion by yourself and then it
becomes this weird government conspiracy
thing and there's rabbits and hands
across America and like when in a music
park and and it becomes it loses the
threat of what made it so captivating in
the beginning which is who are these
people what did they give up to be where
they are and is their past coming back
to haunt them in ways that are awful and
wonderful and and just candy-coated
dread and it seems as if and I was
talking to Clark about this before that
Jordan he reminds me a bit of M night
Shyamalan in that and lights camera can
conjure mood like nobody's business
but he is so hell-bent on having a twist
ending that sometimes he just forgets to
tell a story
he is so actively interested in well
this is what it really is when what it
was was better you know like I like the
village up until it's not the village
anymore like his fighting words I like
the village
it's until it's like what I'm in like
modern-day Pennsylvania you if you
haven't seen it you've never gonna sign
now
like what's killing these people the
trees yellow reading lists Iannuzzi de
are those the great there's another but
you guys just the trees for the record I
do Jardin in my M night Shyamalan so I
love you I love you just the way you are
so so us for me started as an amazing
look and at this family and the things
that they had to go through to get where
they are it was the very essence of what
he talks about a social horror and then
it just becomes like big for big sake
and it loses me a bit well one of the
things that I will keep it on the
positive one of the things that I loved
about this movie was the inspiration I
don't know I'm a big Twilight Zone fan
in there's an episode called
mirror-image
that was the inspiration for the film
which I thought that was probably the
most terrifying thing that I've seen so
please watch that Netflix yes which is
unlace which I highly recommend watching
um and the other thing I'll say about
this film is Lupita Nyong'o was acting
her face off like she killed this role
and I'm gonna be really mad if she
doesn't get nominated for an Academy
Award yeah yeah and I think that like
similarly there's another there's a new
Twilight Zone episode called shatter day
which follows Bruce Willis back when he
was a young and hungry actor as a guy
who slowly discovers that there's
another version of himself that's
stealing his life out from under him and
so he's just trying to live his life but
the other version is better at it and
like steals his job and steals his wife
and steals his house and steals
everything leaving like prime Bruce
Willis depressed and furious and
murderous trying to kill the news
version of himself who I don't quite
remember the twist so I'm not going to
spoil it because I can't but I'm gonna
I'm gonna
assume that he gets arrested for like
attempted murder and ends up in jail
because they knew him had him arrested
for trying to take over the old his life
if that's not it it should be it's like
a bummer or multiplicity so you very
much like Christ horn so the thing about
us that that both excited me and made me
a little bit sad by the end of it is
that Jordan Peele is so very good at
this and and much like I think M Knight
needs to do much as I think Spike Lee
figured out he needed to do as well was
hire a writer like find some of us to
come in and like just work this [ __ ]
through have somebody you can ask
questions so we can respond to you with
artist choice because I don't disagree
it was this I I liked the big swing of
it all right and it wasn't until we got
down hopefully you've seen it so no
spoilers but once we went to that place
in the third act where I was like oh wow
like this is there's a lot of exposition
happening to make this understood for
the audience and I was like you're right
we didn't necessarily have to go there
but I was also like I like that you
tried that you know did you see the big
reveal coming without saying what it is
like did you see it yes and that's what
I thought it was gonna be something else
yeah then I was really surprised and at
that choice because I was like Jordan is
a cinephile yep nobody knows movies and
genre like Jordan knows and to Telegraph
it in such a way but and which is fine
like if you get to that place and then
it's like it's not about the surprise
it's about whatever else totally cool
like sign me up but the movie felt like
it needed or it was saying gotcha
and then I was like but no we knew this
right I liked it yeah I mean I liked it
I enjoy with a controversial quick I
liked that it was starting a
conversation right when I was leaving
the theater when I saw that everyone was
like wait what did that mean and what I
thought what were the rabbits and you
know I I I think it's interesting
to create a mythology within the world
of this one movie where not everything
is explained but he dangles maybe the
possibility of there being some
explanation it's just over there and
we'll get to it someday you know yeah I
don't know he did try to explain and it
was not great to your point about Lupita
she's so good
she's so not your point earlier when
you're introducing this film this feels
like it came out so long ago it was this
year this year guys eight months ago
which is a shame to me because we're in
awards season now yeah and literally
this week everyone's raving about like
Little Women or whatever and there's no
way that Saoirse Ronan does half of what
Lupita was truck was doing in us but you
know like I hope to see her name come up
look there's nothing against there
Sharona and I love her I'm sure no she's
great but I'm like I need a Kathy Bates
moment to happen I feel like horror
films getting so like disrespected and
she needs to get an award nomination at
the least please bring us all back for
that episode of this podcast because I
have things to say about genre and
acclaim yeah and awards like it is I
think hereditary Babbage so many things
that Lupita
so Mull okay anyway different but I
don't know how we manifest those at
least getting Lupita back in the Oscar
conversation yeah absolutely
tell us some [ __ ] okay that is the end
of our hard discussion thank you so much
for playing with with everybody up here
and so now we're gonna move on to Q&A
where you can ask any / all of us
whatever [ __ ] questions you want we
are going to be giving away two tickets
to the 40x theater that is nearest to
you this is a movies for people who
don't like going outside but want to
feel things wait wait can you just
describe the image on these tickets well
it's like naked no flesh-colored [ __ ] oh
yeah I think you got the right idea Jen
I think that's what that image is trying
it if they thought it's porn then that's
what happens
well that's 40 X X 1/4 I've no idea it's
like is it where the chairs shake that
is not just with a chair set the chairs
are keyed to the movies well yeah so
like if you're watching if you're
watching Star Wars and the crawl is
going over your head oh yeah yeah I do
know it back and if there's wind over
there this win this rain and there's
like this amount of screeching tires and
gunpowder and it's sensory overload like
if you live in a bubble feel like I was
just kidding I know what that is it's
just that the image is it looks like it
looks like sexy time very suggest looks
like it looks like vampires vampires so
yes thanks to Brett deacon and the good
folks at 40x we have those tickets we
also have a signed poster maybe the best
of these posters thanks to Megan's allas
over there this this is going in my
house your social media the dark innate
returns and this is signed by all of us
who were up here today so we're given
that away and I brought a couple of
Castle rocks for my private stash
[Laughter]
but yes and I will I will sign those if
you want them signed I'll just give it
to you if you want to put on eBay I'll
give a [ __ ] I won't be hurt so yes if
anybody's got questions by all means man
JC will be taking Jen's mic the way
you've got another one so you get if you
get some time bonus cold times on into
that I'm stealing one check check see if
we can do this without feeding all these
just for me high low
I know Lowell see you right great panel
great podcast so far I'm definitely
gonna try to watch these movies tomorrow
yeah Halloween and chill
so my question so I love animated movies
and there's a stigma that animation is
just for kids but there's a lot of
animated movies that are really
horrifying if you I mean I don't have to
list them I think everybody yes exactly
so my question is well it's two
questions one what is an animated movie
that scared you that most as a kid and
do you think we'll ever get an r-rated
animated horror movie great question and
I mean whose skin me the most as a kid I
mean the Black Cauldron was a little
[ __ ] up mine is also a Disney yeah but
I think I I would go Coraline because in
its another one of those I will show it
to my kids and oh dear God it's about
like a little girl who is like estranged
from her mother who meets another mother
who wants it so buttons into her hangers
you know and like that is a horrifying
thought if you're a child who's lost and
like all I want is my mom I found my mom
she wants to do awful [ __ ] things to
me in order for me to stay but she's my
mom so maybe I will but I don't like its
it twists all of those things that you
want to be able to trust as a child and
it is done with such care and joy and
wonder yeah and I think there's at this
point like a handful of people still
doing stop-motion animation and like is
is killing it
I want more aardman that's just me like
curse of the were-rabbit is also pretty
great but yeah I go Coraline my the one
that scared me as a kid was Sleeping
Beauty Maleficent scared the [ __ ] out of
me
her eyes glowing in the fireplace like
what no I was a scared kid that scared
me
i but Coraline ParaNorman and Monster
House I think is like the trifecta of
scary but and you know it's interesting
um Hector Navarro who is a person that I
do
DC daily with and who also I just love
in general is the biggest advocate for
animation that you will meet and
basically saying animation is a medium
not a genre and I love that and so it's
interesting because when you think about
Coraline or ParaNorman or Monster House
these are movies that are you know quote
fingers geared for children maybe
because they star children they star
children right in the animation or they
follow children as their main characters
but they're dealing with really serious
mature real things and I think that what
we saw like for instance to use stranger
things as an example you know in terms
of like oh you can't have a TV show that
follows kids it's not a kids show right
well stranger things just went yeah or
you can it said Oh or you can and that's
scary and it's the used to be the you
know it's the second biggest r-rated
movie of all time so my point is I think
what it will take is an
advocate who has money to make a more
you know adult-themed
or serious animated film that is
actually scary but it but you know if if
Black Cauldron or Sleeping Beauty is any
indication there the tools have been
there for sixty years so I that's what I
think the first thing that I thought of
was also stop-motion I thought of tales
from the hood which was yeah absolutely
terrifying which I highly recommend and
if people also haven't seen this great
documentary called hard noir oh my god
yes executive produced but tanana Reeve
do it's a really great documentary about
the history of black horror and it's
wonderful streaming on shudder yes
stream you know shudder I love all these
bugs but the real answer is Pinocchio
because oh my god when they were on the
ant on that island they turned into
donkeys
I feel like Disney has traumatized a lot
of people I I have a couple of and I
guess it would be called considered
adult animated movies that I remember
watching as a kid that weren't
necessarily horror but I love them and
they're definitely too grown-up for me
at the time cool world Who Framed Roger
Rabbit was yeah but pretty scary things
and okay okay maybe um okay this isn't
scary but I want to show it up Bebe's
kids
I watched an awful lot and then it's in
terms of an animated movie that scared
me as a child like legit scared me like
the images horrified me I was like four
years Ralph Bakshi's Lord of the Rings
from 1978 which is also beautiful but
it's very haunting in a way that I never
found the live-action movie where
there's a rift in a way and I think
there are a handful if not
basketful if not truck full of Japanese
animated films that are just frightening
as [ __ ] like you know Death Note even
even attack on Titan it's super weird
and gory and awful and like Oh flesh
monsters walking around eating people
that's for kids
but yeah I hope that answer your
question
thank you so many prizes where we go JC
hi what's good give like this spotlight
all right you know how do you spell it
okay dead to me what's your question
like is event horizon horror and yeah
why am I scared of and what do you think
about science fiction and horror love it
I love this question two great tastes
that taste great together peanut butter
and chocolate they go together
it's like flies to honey yeah I used to
do a show eyes in honey ooh
I used to do a show called Collider
nightmares was on the quieter Channel
and it was thankful and but but I bring
it up because I called it nightmares
specifically because I didn't want to
call it Collider horror talk I didn't
want to call it like the shot weird
genre parameters we put around things I
think whatever it gives you nightmares
counts as horror like and so I actually
feel very strongly about this this
question because yeah but I do think
that at the core of it is like this
stigma of what horror is and I think a
lot of people when they think horror
they go oh I don't like horror because I
don't like torture porn I don't like
horror because I don't like slasher
movies so I don't like horror movies
it's horror genre
medium shana i think it's a genre but
yeah i mean that's that's my two senses
like what if event horizon makes you
scared then its horror
you know like Rosemary's Baby scares the
[ __ ] out of me but you know a lot of
people I've talked to when I was putting
together a horror list with somebody the
the consensus was I don't think it's
really very scary and it's like okay
well what scares you is different than
what scares me is different than what
scares someone you know what I mean so
anyway I I do think there are some
common horror themes and things but yeah
I think I think if event horizon gives
you nightmares then it counts I think if
people are being killed off or going
crazy on a spaceship that's more yeah I
mean I think the fly is both horror and
science fiction like it it doesn't exist
without the science fiction part of it
because unless it's was [ __ ] magic
but it's not magic it's about science
it's about trying to do one thing and
here's the unintended side effect and
that is awful you know all the alien
movies as well there there's horror
movies to me we've got to go on we must
go on it's a haunted house that was
always the design yeah alien was gonna
be a haunted house movie in space I
think the Terminator is a horrible
upgrade that is also science fiction
that is also a romance yeah but it's he
absolutely will not stop ever until
you're dead is what you say about any
other [ __ ] slash Michael Myers its
Bruce the shark Oh any yeah I mean he's
a serial killer he's literally going
like oh you're Sarah Connor oh yes sir
they didn't say that in the movie yeah
we got a [ __ ] copycat seal killer
whatever like it is every bully who's
ever had a bad obsession for the nerd
and like you can't stop the car I think
science fiction may be the most
malleable genre in that it mates very
well with lots of different things how
you know there's movies like Terminator
which is science fiction horror
there's straight-up like
science fiction which is Star Wars there
is romance science fiction you know
somewhere in time or Charlie's you know
I mean everything with time travel is
suddenly science fiction and also
everything else that it is so it's like
back to the future is a science fiction
comedy about Parenthood and like finding
love and all that [ __ ] like it it is the
the on-ramp to your story and if that
thing involves fake-ass science then
suddenly it's science fiction space
buddies science fiction space buddies
transformers well here's the thing
terminator dark fate I don't think it's
horror right I would agree with that
which I think happens a lot in
franchises when sequels go on and on and
on it's just a roller coaster in the
same way that aliens is not horror it
has it has one of the great jump scares
in all of movies but it's a war movie
like annum by design like James Cameron
will say no I made a war picture that
happened to be like that one was a
horror movie this is a war movie the
next one is or whatever the [ __ ] that is
Prison movie I'm asking too many
questions but did you ever see Prince of
Darkness oh yeah I also feel like this
is a really good opportunity to plug
memory the origins of alien which I am
in which is available it's a great
documentary about alien and you should
watch it it's available on VOD I also
think this is a great opportunity to
plug your shirt Clerk what oh my gosh it
is a Deborah Hill production everyone
and my houses and them at the beginning
Wow
it is teased on scene these they they
highlight yeah female directors or and
producers and co and you know artists
and r.i.p Deborah Hill she was a cool
cool lady and she's responsible for a
lot of your favorite things did we
answer your question thank you
awesome awesome we have some [ __ ] mark
has
terminator dark fate already come out no
Friday okay have you seen anything Sarah
Connor so I'm their middle very well
Linda Hamilton is a natural tracer oh
yes
no one holds a shotgun like that woman
ah she is also super cool I have had the
pleasure have you interviewed her this
week two days ago she gave me a hug
actually several she's a hugger she's a
hugger and she was a hug for you guys
she's the coolest I love it she's cool a
she's also a twin right oh yeah yeah
that is how they did most of the DMV
effects [ __ ] in Terminator 2 of like her
in the other mirror and her walking up
on herself with a shotgun she's got a
twin yep this is what we're here's where
to drop these pearls of knowledge just
Susanoo hey man what's your name
hey I'm Danny what was it Danny Danny
yep
Danny okay what can we do you for Danny
my question is if you can take the cow
book world and the horror world and have
them have a cross over what would it be
and can I go first cuz I have a really
good idea oh well while we dial into
this what's your idea Punisher vs. chud
okay I could see them exactly you know
that that makes it a storyline where
he's fighting underworld you know he
ends up in the sewers and there's a
bunch of cannibalistic humanoid
underground dwellers you're talking like
specifically like a versus
I'm just saying like yeah I mean Frank
castles in that world or in someone
else's world too so okay I got one
versus but you know are they gonna be
friends yeah a crossover okay I got one
a nightmare on Graymalkin Lane where
Freddy Krueger is haunting infesting
[ __ ] with Charles Xavier and so what
happens when the most powerful telepath
and
world can't go to sleep and what happens
when everybody else has to share that
dudes dreams and as [ __ ] up as his
brain is and now that it's Charles
Xavier murder brain it's kind of what
I'm looking for Wow I can tell boom Mike
dropped whatever I all right I got one
look it's actually based on a real thing
and I googled that I wasn't just tech
look at y'all cheating looking stuff on
Google I know I looked it up um I
actually read this last year cuz it came
out last year it's called Wonder Woman
and the Justice League dark the witching
hour has anyone in this room read it
that's okay read it so basically uh
Hecate the goddess or witch de jour from
history and all sorts of mythology talks
in filter they're really good
infiltrates diana and she's apparently
been there forever and she infiltrates
her and the Amazons it's an awesome
Justice League dark crossover when I
read this I was like first of all I was
rabid for it like I wanted every issue
immediately but also the visuals I'm
seeing what happens and it's it's all
about witches and monsters demons in his
badass and it is so cool and and you get
to seed evil Diana which I'm like yes so
anyway that's it witching hour like it
came out in 2018 if you if you are
interested in this like really pick up
this run it is super super cool sweet
let us see it on the big screen what you
got uh I got anything good you guys are
too good at this game
I'll tell I'll be on okay I'll be honest
since this doesn't leave this room no
it's just us just as kids I was just
picturing Howard the Duck in all a lot
of horror movies and I couldn't figure
out which one I
Howard the Duck destroys the universe
that would be kinda cool
Oh God like your answer was way better I
can't yeah I didn't adding Google I'm
not gonna cheat I'm not gonna be like
certain people on this panel I'll just
say um look we can just do any crossover
of any version of storm from the x-men
in any kind of like vampire lesbian
situation I'm there for it excellent The
Hunger remember that yes firestarter oh
yeah this versus firestarter that would
be awesome water be fire versus planet
seriously what is scarier than the time
it's a storm move I've these aquifers
that's breathe scary to me look at a
John Cheetos Captain Planet would be a
yes go try the hallways be fun
Ghost Rider storm would be fun yeah but
I needed you you you I just bounce off
of you we just need storm anybody don't
wear shoes like I'm saying here hot and
there's rain and there's like another
lady who's a little evil I could fight
you or or I thank you guys to take a
meeting with hey Kevin Feige here's my
pitch war look if we're not gonna be
able to watch any movies from Fox or
Disney ever again at least let us get
some storm action in there like a storm
is it worth it for us Reyes store full
storm frontal all right well you said it
not me
and on that note thank you for your
questions thank you totally
don't tell me these give me like if I
can bring her posters to my show ladies
and gentlemen I think that is all the
show we have for you tonight did you
have a good time you guys are awesome
thank you so much for coming out on like
crazy busy Halloween week when I know
there's like apples you could be bobbing
for razors you could be putting in
apples what I have to set up the angry
shirt day angry girl thank you so much
to my co-hosts for coming out again on
what is the busiest week of the year
especially for some of them Jen Yamato
Clark whoa yeah Latoya Morgan find them
all on the Internet they're all off
somewhere you an awesome [ __ ] [ __ ]
and thank you this has been another
episode of black man Beyond I am mark
Renard and come back next week same
black time same black channel SModcast
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
you